let's cross back to andrew simmons he's
live for us in the ukrainian capital
kiev andrew apologies for that things
are happening so fast uh on the ground
both at the un and where you are you are
bringing us up to date with what you're
hearing and seeing there on the ground
both in kiev
and in other cities tell us what's been
happening
multiple attacks on cities right across
the country the foreign minister dimitro
kuleba
has just tweeted that
the country is under full-scale invasion
uh by russia uh he says peaceful cities
uh are under attack uh he's referring to
airstrikes and we can confirm there have
been a number of large explosions uh
here in the capital kiev that the
airport boris bill international airport
seemed to be the first target there was
a lot of uh gunfire here from there we
thought but we wouldn't initially it
sounded like artillery fire coming in
coming but it appears a lot of this has
been air strikes within the city blaring
sirens power cut for a short while here
some panic going on in some areas of the
city naturally with this situation we're
also hearing that a number of other
cities have come under attack and no
information on casualties yet mario paul
on the coastline has come under attack
in the east we're not sure of the
situation in donbass the area where the
two republics
are aware all of the russian
troops maneuvered initially uh three
days ago
kramatorsk
is where we have a correspondence she is
reporting what she thinks is outgoing
fire from there that the ukrainians are
resisting here in the city
there is a bit of a lull now but the
last
large explosion
was around about four or five minutes
ago
the
whole atmosphere here is one of of
tension and fear there have been some
indications that there could be
attacks on this night but no one had
really prepared for this uh
several you know several cities are
being under attack simultaneously uh we
have heard from uh
reports uh that have been confirmed that
the russian navy who had a number uh of
vessels in the as of sea uh they have uh
two of the two very large landing ships
uh have uh they've actually got into
odessa which is the main naval port uh
on the back sea which uh they're there
are confirmed to have landed troops and
and armory so really we're getting uh it
would appear
that full-scale attacks from land sea
and it would appear air
the uh the situation uh in
genetics and luhansk
is unclear those are the two uh people's
republics as they're called where
russian uh military has uh moved forward
in that in those areas we're not sure
exactly what's going on there yeah
andrew as you say a multi-faceted uh
operation against ukraine air land and
sea you were telling us just before we
left you the last time that you'd heard
reports of a naval landing uh in odessa
and obviously you've just confirmed that
again andrew let me ask you as you're in
the ukrainian capital kiev has there
been any increased security or military
activity by the ukrainians in the
capital what are they saying or doing
they're we're they're not it's too early
to actually get any reaction from them
right now uh we can hear the sirens but
it has to be said despite all the
reports yet again of invasions it didn't
seem last night we were driving uh back
from a from a location uh in the south
east and we we did not really get the
impression that there was a massive
scaling up of operations however we did
see a number of reserves with uh with
military equipment and uh president
zielenski had actually um
called for the reserves to be to be
actually amassed and brought into into
uh into action uh anybody aged between
18 and 60 years of age but a lot of
people were asking why there wasn't a
full-scale mobilization of forces uh it
didn't seem that that was was the case
and we we were actually at a border post
where uh russia uh uh ukraine uh and uh
and belarusia uh belarus uh uh com
converged together a three-way uh border
post and things were pretty calm there
there was no indication that there was
going to be any any action with the
there were some patrols but though it on
the whole it didn't seem as if this
country had really geared itself up for
full-scale invasion i could be wrong but
as i say we have these these bombings
going on um we're not sure whether
they're all air strikes in this in the
capital yet uh but the foreign minister
has tweet is continually tweeting uh
about this uh aggression from russia uh
and this is now what something like it's
more than an hour since uh
since uh we had that declaration of war
from moscow uh with vladimir putin uh uh
once again going through the reasons uh
his aggression he described it which
ukraine denies point blank ever occurred
and he has his intent on
on this invasion uh remember three
nights ago when
when he was actually outlining the
reasons for recognizing the two
breakaway republics in the southeast in
the donbass he said the reasoning for
this was that ukraine
was attacking uh people there so this is
a situation now which is
well it's critical right now we don't
know the scale of casualties but this is
a very very dark night indeed uh in
ukraine all right andrew simmons and kev
andrew will no doubt come back to you as
things develop um just to bring our
viewers up to date uh the ukrainian
foreign is now saying that russia has
launched a full-scale invasion of
ukraine these are some of the pictures
uh we have seen come into us a little
bit earlier of the capital kiev let's
just watch and see these pictures now
in terms of the explosions and the
attack in the ukrainian capital let's
just see them play again
now